we're heading towards a major cliff dive
or call it jumping the shark to use a
television term or whatever term you
prefer not only is Donald Trump
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
considering resignation over how Donald
Trump treated Jeff Sessions in that
recent New York Times interview more on
that a little bit later Donald Trump
recently spoke to advisors about firing
the Attorney General jeff Sessions Trump
has been speculating out loud to his
advisors recently about what would
happen if I were to fire the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions according to three
different people who have spoken to
President Trump directly this being on
his mind is corroborated by his public
tweets over the last 24 hours Donald
Trump recently tweeting quote so why
aren't the committees and investigators
and of course our beleaguered Attorney
General looking into crooked Hillary's
crimes and Russia relations he also
tweeted this morning quote Attorney
General Jeff Sessions has taken a very
weak position on Hillary Clinton crimes
where our emails and DNC excuse me
server and Intel leakers didn't Trump
say after he was elected that he was no
longer interested in the whole pudding
Hillary Clinton in jail thing and now
he's slamming his own attorney general
because he's not going after Hillary
Clinton now you might be wondering what
did Jeff Sessions do that's so bad that
Donald Trump is considering firing him
it sounds kind of weird the reason is
the same thing as what was irritating to
trump in last week's New York Times
interview Donald Trump is angry with
Jeff Sessions because Jeff Sessions
recused himself on anything related to
Trump Russia still you might say okay
but David that happened a while ago why
now is Trump losing his mind over that
it seems that it's Robert Muller looking
into Trump's personal business dealings
which has really set Trump off now why
would that lead to Trump being mad at
Jeff Sessions here's the path I'm going
to give you insight into the mind of
Trump Trump believes if Jeff Sessions
hadn't recused himself on Russia
Robert Moeller would
have been appointed and thus Trump would
never be in this mess right now if it
weren't for Jeff Sessions is recusal
this of course ignores several important
facts one is that Trump fired James
Comey and that played big lis into the
appointment of a special prosecutor and
also it's that that pesky little fact
that the Trump team has been lying about
Russia for months which played a role in
the appointment of a special prosecutor
this pad is really a microcosm of the
Trump presidency right the one thing
that Jeff Sessions did that we can say
you know what that was the right
decision he was involved in lies about
Russia it's correct for him to recuse
himself on anything related to Russia
that's what's making Trump consider
firing sessions now and also looking
forward I think he wants someone to fire
Moeller the special prosecutor but he
doesn't want to do it himself because he
understands it would be incredible
blowback if he did that yeah and maybe
not just Muller maybe Rosenstein maybe
McCabe all have been criticizing both
mccabe and possibly i mean certainly
Moeller and i don't know about
Rosenstein yeah back before he was doing
that too and i think he just he wants
them to be out but he wants the Attorney
General to do it for him and Phil
there's there's it's unclear whether
Trump could fire Moeller they're sort of
did legal disagreement on that but what
this gets us back to is Trump still
thinks firing people might make things
go away and if there's anything that a
normal person would have learned over
the last few months it's that when you
fire people it doesn't make things go
away I hope that Jeff Sessions does not
resign I hope he stays and that Donald
Trump fires him because that would be
way way worse for Donald Trump and you
know how could Jeff Sessions stay at
this point you know it's interesting how
Jeff Sessions is a horrible guy when it
comes to civil rights when it comes to
gay rights and marijuana and yet maybe
it's better off that he stays or that
Trump is forced into firing him because
now he's providing some sort of buffer
in this whole Russia story if you had
said to me six months ago there's going
to be a situation in July where you're
going to be saying I hope Jeff Sessions
doesn't resign I would have said no that
that could never happen but that's where
we are I hope Jeff Sessions doesn't
resign and that Donald Trump's fire the
Donald Trump fires him the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com/scishow
Pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad